بعد تعليق رحلاتها في البحر الاحمر
استانفت شركه الشحن ميرسك ابحارها بعد
انشاء الولايات المتحده قوه عمل بحريه
باسم حارس الازدهار لمنع هجمات انصار الله
الحوثيين على السفن
التجاريه هذه احدى السفن سفن الحاويات
المتجهه من سنغافوره الى قناه سويس او في
طريقها لقناه السويس استهدف الحوثيون هذه
السفينه واسمها ميرت هانجتشو بصواريخ
بحريه وصفوها بالمناسبه بعد ان رفضت
الاستجابه لنداءات تحذيريه طبعا الولايات
المتحده اعترضت هذه الصواريخ واسقطت لكن
الذي حصل ان سفينه ميرسك هانشو اطلقت
نداءات استغاثه في السادسه والنصف صباحا
وهو اليوم التالي خلال 24 ساعه يعني من
تعرضها للهجوم الاول لانها تعرضت لاربع
زوارق صغيره تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين
اطلقت النار على السفينه بالاسلحه الخفيفه
ووصلت الى قرابه 20 مترا منها افشل الفريق
الامني في السفينه محاوله صعود المقاتلين
على متنها وردوا باطلاق النار استجابت
المروحيات الامريكيه لنداءات السفينه
لابعاد القوارب نادت عليهم ان ابتعدوا من
هنا عندما ردت القوارب باطلاق النار على
المروحيه
الامريكيه اغرقت نيران المروحيات ثلاثه
منها وقتلت طواقمها بالكامل فيما فر
الرابع نحو شواطئ اليمن المتحدث العسكري
باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين يحيى سريع
تحدث عن تفاصيل ما جرى وهذا ما
قاله اقدمت قوات العدو الامريكي على
الاعتداء على ثلاثه زوارق تابعه للقوات
البحريه اليمنيه ما ادى الى لاستشهاد
وفقدان عشره افراد من منتسب القوات
البحريه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه وهي
تزف في خضم معركه الاسناد لطوفان الاقصى
هؤلاء الشهداء من اجل فلسطين تؤكد ان
العدو الامريكي يتحمل تبعات هذه الجريمه
وتداعياتها وان تحركاته العسكريه في البحر
الاحمر لحمايه السفن الاسرائيليه لن تمنع
اليمن من تاديه واجبه الديني والاخلاقي
والانساني دعما ونصره للمظلومين في فلسطين
وغزه اذا عشره اشخاص هم من قتلوا وفقدوا
في هذه العمليه وفق ما قاله يحيى سريع
مواقع تابعه لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
نشرت هذه الصور وقالت انها للافراد الذين
شاركوا امس الاحد في العمليه وقتلوا
بنيران المروحيات الامريكيه على متن
زوارقهم كيف انتم علقتم على تفاصيل هذه
العمليه في البحر البحر الاحمر وعلى مقتل
عشره اشخاص تابعين لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين ابدا من تغريده فدائي يقول فيها
نحن لا نحتفظ بحق الرد ودماؤنا لا تذهب
هدرا وعلى امريكا ان تستوعب ما يعنيه
اليمن وان تدرك ان التحذير والانذار يتبعه
حمم عبد الرحمن الحوثي يقول لك امريكا
تمارس جريمه القتل وتضن انها ستنجو
بفعلتها وهي لن تنجو تبني جدارا من وهم
القوه لحمايه السفن الاسرائيليه ومصيره
الانهيار والغرق وسط البحر اما طليعه
الشهداء البحريه اليمنيه فقد انتصروا
بالشهاده وكرس بالدم حضور اليمن الى جانب
فلسطين علي ابو
هادي ما يحدث حاليا هو مسرحيه لشرع
التواجد الامريكي احمد يقول يقول لك كل
الروايات الى الان عباره عن بيانات ورقيه
ولم نشاهد شيء حقيقي صباح العواضي وهي اخر
تغريده لهذه الق قصه ارادت امريكا من
مرافقه سفينه تابعه لشركه الشحن
الدنماركيه ميرسك التي غامرت في عبور
البحر الاحمر تحت حراسه التحالف الفاشل ان
تراهن على نجاح التحالف الا انها فشلت
واعتقد انها اخر مغامره لها ولاي شركه
تدعم اسرائيل تعبر مياهنا الاقليميه منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض
جون كيربي يقول ان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى الى صراع اوسع في الشرق الاوسط ولا
تريد صراعا مع الحوثيين وترى ان الافضل ان
يتوقفوا عن الهجمات التي يشنون في البحر
الاحمر